hi herzlich willkommen zur vierten folge
minecraft mauz wir sind hier auf dem
berg bei dem wir uns in lukas letzter
folge aus gelockt haben hey luca und
sind in einem schnee die um gelandet
lukas letzte folge gestorben also
unbedingt bei ihm anschauen das war
ziemlich abenteuerlich wir waren jetzt
die betten ab und wir haben uns letzte
folge entschieden dass wir hier vorgehen
da vorne gibt es nämlich noch mehr
schnee die um und wir dachten uns dass
ein bisschen besser die ist es war
relativ schön aber weil wir diese folge
anfangen wollen uns ein haus zu bauen
dachten wir uns ja das ist vielleicht
ein bisschen wenig platz für ein haus
luca was ist denn ja wir haben jetzt
alle gedacht da hinten so ein riesiger
bären oder hin dass auch das medium und
es ist zwar nicht mehr weihnachten aber
es ist der erste weihnachtsfeiertag
deswegen damals gedacht einmal hinten
rüber du tötest jedoch die hühner oder
bestimmten laufen richtig mache ich so
eine sekunde
ich muss mal ganz kurz falls ihr luca
doppelt gehört habt dann tut mir sehr
leid tue gar ein bisschen hallo mein
name ist luca könnte man meinen kanal
abonnieren wenn ihr genau so ist's
richtig kauft also die folge von heute
wird ich bin ziemlich eine technische
darauf jetzt ist nicht beziehen dass wir
unser haus aufschlagen
ein bisschen rumlaufen bisschen die
gegend erkunden
ein bisschen ja sag ich mal sesshaft
werden allerdings haben wir wieder eine
interessante challenge vorbereitet meine
damen und herren und zwar ist diese
challenge es macht immer wenn ich es
sage sich ein neues t-shirt anziehen
muss das heißt ich glaube die challenge
heißt in england oder amerika t shirt
layer challenge junge meine macken ist
noch so kalt von meiner letzten folge
[Musik]
hatte aber max hat daher sehr oft gesagt
luca kreisel für den nacken deswegen
würde ich sagen direkt zu beginn max bei
mir ging's gestern in der folge um kälte
bei der besoldung wir haben ich will mir
direkt ein t shirt anziehen
ok es in ordnung luca das ist halt so
das ding ich werden wir wahrscheinlich
20 mal so diese folge t shirt über mein
aktuelles t shirt drüber ziehen müssen
aus dem grund schaut auch keine
kopfhörer drin nur so ist es möglich
weil sonst muss ich die ganze zeit
kopfhörer und so weiter und so fort ich
werde mal ein bisschen holz haben jetzt
neben bremerhaven engagiert bitte ich
hab grad in pumps ich hoffe das hat man
nicht gehört
um so auch mehrere bäume augen holz ab
ja genau wobei das ist vielleicht auch
gar nicht so schlecht weil das wird ja
unser werk dann können wir auf dem berg
das ganze holz abbauen dass wir dann
eine schöne große fläche haben eine
ebene fläche
darum wird halt wie gesagt gehen also
wir bauen müssen eben eine schöne fläche
ist das schön hier
es ist eine schöne feier das übel alles
auch mit dem shader und somit dem ganzen
schnee die ganze zeit und diese bäume
jetzt gerade die immer wieder fällt
es muss gar nicht so lange überleben
konnten sie mein körper ich hoffe mal
dass ihr genau so viel spaß hat an
minecraft maut wie wir
falls das so ist dann tut mir jetzt mal
gefallen und liegt das video und
schreibt keine ahnung mir gefällt
minecraft mars oder sowas kommentare das
beste es gibt nichts wichtigeres im
leben wenn leute sagen macht euer abi
macht euer studium macht dies macht das
dann sagte ich mache genau eine sache
und diese sache ist
entweder man hat schon mal so ein
bisschen lieben du kannst schon mal
überlegen was wir für ein haus bauen
ich hab mir früher immer mal karl jarres
oder irgendwie so heißt der kurs der
haie hat immer so tutorials gemacht wie
man gerne minecraft häuser baut wo ich
doch ganz gut sagen weil davon habe ich
nicht erhalten
h ich hoffe es ist erleichtert für dich
zu hören dass ich genau so viel ahnung
davon haben wie man schöne häuser baute
minecraft aber ich mache das hier oben
auf jeden fall die ganze gerade mal eben
logistisch geraten und holz und schwarz
und sonstwas dass wir einfach ein
bisschen essen haben und ich würde auch
nicht sagen da wird schon allein
unterwegs bist ohne mich und es ist
schäbig würde direkt mal zwei t shirts
vorüberziehen zwei auf einmal ich bin
zweiter
ich sitze dann in vier t shirts da luca
wenn ihr fragen sind sie dann 100
hoffentlich gut leute weil es so schön
ist sie ich mir noch zwei t-shirts an
einigen verdammt echt mal leichter
lassen weil ich glaube dass max familie
tatsächlich zu hause heißt das heißt das
finde ich schon bis dahin max mit
filmriss darauf wir können ein super
railway machen von der einen von dem ein
werk zum anderen bereich die klappe ich
will unbedingt gemeinschaften einmal
sondern meinen part bahn machen okay
leute ich hab jetzt 4 t shirts an und es
geht weiter mit ein bisschen holz
verspürt sagen das machen wir jetzt mal
eben und dann treffen uns auf den berg
wieder okay leute ich bin jetzt jeder
bei luca auf dem berg und hab ja
immerhin 33 holz
warum hast du dieses nebeneinander
gefahren weil wir nie eine kiste das
etwas wertvoller reintun und in die
andere kiste das erstmal ein bisschen
scheißegal ist wir wollen wir nicht
doppel kisten machen erstmal kurz
aufteilen
wir machen das wahrscheinlich würde ich
vorschlagen ganz so mit
[Musik]
ich habe keine schneebälle auf die
welche das auch für luca luka häufig
weiter gleich runter
ich habe alles wieder gut luca oder ihr
seid ja aber ich will dass mich geboxt
hat sie die neuen t shirt an
es ist jede folge dasselbe so einer
verarscht den anderen innen also dafür
diese den tieferen das ist der hammer
ich habe er aktuell glaub ich 5 t shirts
an wo mit dem sonnenuntergang hinstellen
genießen
kommen wir ja das ist so cool aus wir
müssen unbedingt den betten der
regierung sonnenuntergang schlafen
hey leute das hier wird es teurer
wallpaper guckt euch das mal bitte
ansprechen neben mich mit mir vorteil
durch kanzlerin endlich das soll so
richtig schön werden minecraft maut
blickt dem sonnenuntergang entgegen
halte ist das schön leute richtig
kurzfilme aufnahme erschreckte mich okay
es wird dunkel
wir schlafen und dann fangen wir auch
gleich noch mit dem haus weg sein was
ich über flash ende wäre wenn wir das
ding hier vorne das ist natürlich so
gewachsen als balkon nehmen würden
das könnte wirklich machen okay das
machen wir jetzt auch braucht eine
schaufel ja wäre super wenn du eine
hätte fast das wurde meistens die zu gut
aus wenn ich das muss ein bisschen
einfach ansätzen mit der erde
dort ist es ist voll in ordnung wir
können ja die die kosmetischen sachen am
ende noch machen so irgendwie welche
angleichen
aber erstmal ja ich sollte jetzt auch
ein bisschen aus wollen wir gold boden
nehmen mehr davon am meisten
ja auf jeden fall aber machen noch nicht
alles zu planen
ich habe alles gemacht nächste folge
wirst du dafür leiden
du leidest jetzt ist jetzt ein t shirt
an junge mann darf doch wohl doch mal
was sagen hey ich durfte nicht sagen du
musst du direkt liegestütze machen
eiswürfel meinen nacken alles ja okay du
hast recht es ist einfach so nervig
jedes mal wenn man gerade was schafft im
projekt luca mit dem t shirt an also
nächste folge wird wahrscheinlich auch
noch mal eine hausbau folge baidu kann
aber dafür finde ich sind halt die
changes super dass wir halt nicht nur
eins macht also nicht nur häuser bauen
oder so sondern halt auch einfach
nebenbei ein bisschen was machen was
selbst wenn wir irgendwie ein bisschen
was in anführungszeichen eintöniges
machen dass da noch ein bisschen
spannung leist und deswegen bin ich mir
auch an einer stelle direkt mal wieder
ein t shirt anziehen ist eigentlich
ziemlich war hier ist eine arme gang
bewegen als wenn dort möglich alles ist
das so schlimm naturschutz ist es so
schlimm nur mit t-shirt
also nein also das gut das war ein
bisschen übertrieben es ist wie so eine
dicke jacke was du unter den arm hast
und es schneidet halt so voll ein und
das ist nicht so schön haben jetzt
gerade schon über eine viertel stunde
aufgenommen und ich finde es wird halt
einfach schön aus und weiß nicht ob das
an shader liegt oder woran auch immer
aber irgendwie sieht alles schön aus und
machen es macht einfach spaß weil wir
wissen halt wirklich nicht mal wie das
projekt ankommen wird aber es macht aber
spaß
wir müssen wissen
mit offenen karten zu spielen wir machen
das ganze hier so ein bisschen müssen
vorproduzieren einfach aus dem grund bei
maxxim ich beide im urlaub sind und bzw
europe china sind wir sind ja alle im
skiurlaub deswegen müssen wir da
wirklich so ein bisschen vorproduzieren
aber ich werde jetzt mal in denen balkon
so ein bisschen schräg gebaut
ja man muss das noch anpassen aber da
konnte ich nicht für mich macht das
ganze schon da bin ich auf der andern
seite dann passen
die eingangstreppe quasi unter browse
machen kann ja ok max zu viele
ich weiß nicht jeder noch eins ja noch
aber muss ich das jetzt machen also
erfordern die maut regeln darf würde
sagen wir fragen mal den chat hat jeder
mensch denn durch das videos gibt und
sich dass wir gerade anschaut und sich
sowieso ein turban um den kopf gebunden
habe fragt sich wahrscheinlich komplett
bescheuert sind die ganze welt schaut es
ist einfach es also wie ich hier gerade
aussehen kann
es ist einfach wenn es einfach komplett
behämmert man die machen gerade schönen
so ein schönes haus hiervon unser
schönes jetzt nicht aber es ist für den
umständen entsprechen ist
na ja soll ich jetzt eigentlich noch
kabel stone mitbringen ja wir brauchen
von allen eigentlich irgendwas also du
musst dich extra farben gehen aber als
ich gerade noch ein bisschen erde dass
wir das oben anpassen können die
plattform
ich habe jetzt auch übrigens falls ich
auch meine zuschauer geparkter weißer
gerade für ein loch gebuddelt habe ich
habe ein loch gemacht dass wir auch von
oben ins wasser springen können und
nicht immer den ganzen weg runter laufen
müssen
das finde ich nämlich auch gerade
klingelschilder für unsere haus klingelt
er will damit leute wissen wenn die
ankommen wo wir wohnen
du meinst die anderen leute die es nicht
gibt auf diesem server mehr alleine
ja und nein
übrigens leute wenn wir gerade vom
server sprechen ich wollte an der schön
auch mal ein großes talent prepaid
hoster aussprechen die haben uns nämlich
den server aufgesetzt und haben sogar
gestern nacht um 2 uhr als wir uns um
entschieden haben von hexe das wollten
wir ursprünglich machen noch den server
gewechselt und sonstwas und die sind
einfach super nett und mache auch sehr
stabile server und deshalb wollte ich
einfach mal ein kleines dankeschön nicht
weiß und lass uns was ist sondern weil
ich einfach wirklich finde das ist
einfach total lieb von ihnen ist dass
wir uns zu unterstützen und das ist
einfach mein kleines dankeschön also die
verlinkt ist ja super lasst uns mal
schlafen gehen was umso schöner gewinn
am einschlafen
hier wohnen max und luca minecraft noch
ausgesprochen
[Musik]
der größte vor lee die obmann
ich schickte erst einmal ein bild dass
du weißt nicht aussehen es sieht auch
noch extrem blöd aus das bild weil ich
gerade die augen hatte aber hierfür das
bild hat kein spaß ist sich lustige
leute hier noch ganz kurz bevor ich die
folge beenden will ich hier vorne noch
auf unserem balkon diesen vorsprung
bauen sodass na ich baute jedes mal
drüber da kann ja gar noch einen crêpe
das sind ja da will ich sagen werden wir
die heutige folge ich gehe es erstmal
diese ganzen features aus lasst uns die
folge beenden auf unserem dingens hier
unserem balkon ja wir werden die
folgelasten bekommt ok einmal wie wir
hier stehen das ist richtig schön ja
leute da würde ich sagen sehen uns beim
nächsten mal wieder hier findet ihr
übrigens noch ein altes video von mir
und hier unten könnt ihr mich gerne
abonnieren falls ihr das noch nicht
getan habe dann würde ich sagen